These are images you've probably never seen
before; it's an atomic bomb detonating in
the heart of the Australian outback. We're used
to hearing about nuclear testing in the United
States, but many Aussies don't realise that
our own country was also a testing ground.
The price Australia paid for this was steep with
devastating impacts on our people and environment.
And to make matters worse, Australia never
got to share in any benefits from these tests.
It was the British using Australia to test its
bombs. They claimed to have cleaned up the site
before handing it back to Australia with a
report saying it was now safe. But in 1984,
more than 20 years after the test program
ended, Australian scientists walked the
land with Geiger counters to check for
radiation and got the shock of their lives.
Expecting to find low levels of contamination,
they wore shorts and no protective clothing,
but instead, their readings fluctuated wildly. As
they stumbled over rocks and soil, they realised
they were treading on plutonium-soaked earth. They
even found chunks of the deadly substance itself.
Plutonium, a man-made element, is created
in a nuclear reactor by bombarding uranium
with neutrons. The isotope in question here is
plutonium-239, which has a half-life of over
24,000 years so remains dangerous
practically forever. Inhaling just
20 milligrams of plutonium
can cause a fatal illness.
The scientists were there to survey
the land before it was to be handed
back to the traditional owners, the Maralinga
Tjarutja people, who were displaced in their
hundreds by the tests. The Australians were
shocked and unprepared for what they found.
The British had claimed to have cleaned up
any contamination, and a report put together
by UK scientist Noah Pearce made no mention of
these deadly plutonium fragments. It's enough
radioactive material that international laws
would require it to be safeguarded from bad
actors trying to make a bomb. It also contains
secret traces of how the British bombs were put
together but was just left lying out in the
desert unguarded and undisclosed for decades.
In the 50s and 60s the British detonated 12
major atomic bombs and performed hundreds
of related experiments across Australia,
leaving parts of the country permanently
contaminated by deadly radiation.
It’s a story of negligence and harm
that starts with a few physicists and a
seemingly worthless heavy metal: uranium.
It's the heaviest of all natural elements and was
known to have more neutrons
than protons in its nucleus.
Bombarding the nucleus with neutrons
at high speed could cause it to split,
undergoing nuclear fission. In 1938,
researchers in Paris discovered that
the uranium atom flings out extra neutrons
when split. Noone initially thought those
neutrons could be harnessed or controlled
for anything, but soon theories of a chain
reaction made a bomb possible. Neils Bohr and
John Wheeler published a memo on the fission
process just three days before war broke out,
putting everyone on the same starting line.
Uranium-235 could easily sustain a chain
reaction where the neutrons flung out by
one nucleus splitting would cause other nuclei
to split, each time releasing a great deal of
energy. A material reaches critical mass
when more neutrons can go off and split
other nuclei than are lost in the reaction. Otto
Frisch and Rudolf Peierls working in England,
found that just a few pounds of uranium-235
were needed to reach critical mass.
The British secretly worked on this idea
under a deliberately boring-sounding name,
Tube Alloys. The British were well in
front of the Americans at this stage,
and in 1941 British research was given
to the US, where it fueled the Manhattan
project that culminated in the dropping of
bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki in 1945.
After this, the US didn't need the British
anymore, and after a couple of high-profile atomic
spies were discovered, they didn't trust the UK
to keep secrets. UK physicists were shut out,
and the Atomic Energy Act was introduced by the
US in 1946 that banned collaboration on nuclear
weapons development. It took the British by
surprise, and this betrayal was why Britain
turned to developing their own bombs and
ended up coming to Australia to test them.
Australia had its own
reasons for allowing them to.
1. Australia wanted to maximise the value
of their extensive uranium resources.
2. They thought that helping the British
could protect them in case of nuclear war.
3. They wanted to learn from the British in
case they decided to make their
own nuclear weapons or energy.
However, the British provided no nuclear secrets
to Australia, and Australia was reluctant to ask.
Australia was an ideal location for the
British tests. There were vast areas of land,
we had a prime minister who said yes without
asking too many questions and well it
wasn't Britain and any harm would be out of
sight and out of mind for them. The British
arrived in Australia in 1952 and tested their
first atomic bomb at the Montebello Islands.
They were keen to test the effects
of detonating a weapon in the hold
of a ship and analyse the specifics
of a phenomenon called base surge,
which involved a large upward
movement of radioactive water.
The weapon was 25 kilotons which is 10 kilotons
more than the bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima
so it was a very powerful weapon. It
was one of the most powerful, not the,
but one of the most powerful bombs detonated in
Australia. It did spread fallout over a wide area,
that is still actually being investigated
scientifically. I do know from my own research
that the fallout went as far as Brisbane
so it was tracked across the continent.
For the next tests, the British moved to Emu Field
in the Australian desert. There Operation Totem
detonated more bombs, this time testing the impact
of differing proportions of plutonium. They left a
kilometre-wide patch where the earth was heated
to such high temperatures that it became glass.
Totem One which was detonated on the 15th
of October of 1953 created a very mysterious
phenomenon that later became known as the Black
Mist. We still don't fully understand what the
Black Mist was. We do know that it traveled
about 170 kilometers to the northeast of
the Emu Field site where it rolled over largely
indigenous populations around the settlements of
Wallatinna and Granite Downs, that kind of area.
We know that it was a very strange phenomenon,
a greasy black cloud that had a strange smell.
Some people said it smelled like kerosene other
people said it smelled like a dead kangaroo and
it stuck to everything and very soon after the
Black Mist rolled over those communities people
started to get very ill and some people died.
Some people had chronic illnesses, some people
reported eye problems and indeed blindness.
Next Britain's Focus shifted to testing a
hydrogen bomb before an international treaty
to limit nuclear weapons testing took effect.
Since hydrogen bombs are even more powerful
than Atomic ones, Australia did actually put
its foot down and said no to testing them. So
instead the British just tested a device that
could operate as a fission trigger for one and
this remains the biggest Atomic device ever
to explode in Australia. It was tested back
at the Montebello Islands in June 1956. Its Cloud
rose 14 000 meters high, so different from what
authorities had predicted that many people
thought something had gone terribly wrong.
Back in the desert in 1956-57 this time
at a more permanent base at Maralinga,
seven more atomic bombs were detonated as
part of Operations Buffalo and Antler. These
were detonated in a few ways; from steel towers,
dropped from aircraft or from tethered balloons
300 meters high. There was also Buffalo 2
detonated at ground level that created a 21
meter deep bomb crater. Damage from these tests
spread over a large part of the continent but
the worst was still to come. The most dangerous
scientific experiments in Australia's history
were the Vixen B series of so-called minor
trials conducted between 1959 and 1963.
The minor trials, and that name is rather
ironic and it's kind of deliberate as well
it was intended to be misleading, they
were extremely dangerous and extremely
damaging. The Vixen B trial involved using
conventional explosives to detonate a lump
of plutonium. This is a test to see what
would happen if an aircraft carrying
an atomic weapon crashed or caught fire or you
know there was some accident or even terrorism.
There were 12 Vixen B tests altogether and in
one of those we know for sure a chain reaction
did eventuate, so that is it was a small
atomic weapon. The rest of them were more
like what would be known today as dirty bombs,
suitcase bombs, they were they just spread the
radioactive material in a plume shape across the
landscape. Essentially Vixen B left more than 20
kilograms of plutonium-239 at the site without
any safeguards and that had implications later
for international agreements that Australia
was party to but also just for anyone who
happened to enter that territory they were at
risk of exposure to highly dangerous material.
Secrecy and coverups meant the British nuclear
tests in Australia remained mysterious for
decades. Until a Royal Commission presented
the findings of its investigations 1985,
Australia really had no idea what had gone on.
The tests massively disrupted
and harmed the Aboriginal people,
who didn't have the federal vote and were not
counted in the census until 1967. In Maralinga,
people spotted living on the land were
directed to a station at Yalata. Still,
small groups did walk across the
grounds after the tests began.
The native Patrol Officer William McDougall and
his offside Bob McCauley they had the task of
keeping Aboriginal people away from the site
and that was an impossible task given the size
of the territory and the the routes between
water holes and people visiting family you
know it was a it was a busy place and people
were traversing the territory all the time.
One particularly famous example of that happening
during the tests was the Milpuddie family. They
walked onto the Maralinga range in 1957
several months after a test had been held
at a site called Marcoo, the only bomb test at
Maralinga that involved detonating a device on
the ground and so it created a crater, a
very deep and wide crater. The Milppuddie
family camped by the side of that crater. They
weren't found until a patrol the next morning
and they were hastily taken away it was the
father mother and children and some dogs
and they were rather brutally showered
and had geiger counters run over them.
On the orders of Minister for Supply Howard
Beale their dogs were shot in front of them.
Edie Milpuddie, the wife was pregnant at the
time and she lost her baby soon after. There
were plenty of other instances where people were
treated just as harshly placed onto trucks taken
away to places on The Great Australian bite to
missions and places like that were you know losing
contact with their land and so the Milpuddie
story is an important one on a human level to
understand what happened to real people who were
displaced and mistreated by the British trials.
The British did not accurately
describe what they were leaving
behind. Low-rank military personnel put
together the data in the Pearce report,
and their measurements lacked an understanding of
how radiation could be dispersed. That was strange
since understanding the dispersal of radiation
and its consequences for the environment was
an important part of what the British hoped
to gain from the tests in the first place.
There's still quite a bit of controversy
about whether or not that was adequate
however I'm satisfied that the site is much
safer than it was before the cleanup. There
is still limits on visiting there. There are
time limits on how long you can spend on the
site and no one can stay there indefinitely in
the Forward Range part of the of the Maralinga
range. The half-life of plutonium-239 is
24400 years so it you don't get rid of it
on human time scales anyway. So yes, no one
will ever be able to inhabit those places.
The state that Emu field and Monte Bello were
left in by the British was not much better,
and today there are still signs up warning
tourists not to stay longer than an hour.
Australia fronted many of the running
costs and gave political backing and
military personnel but was never in
charge or privy to the information
gained. The media was muzzled
by strict government censorship,
and the general public was kept in the dark
about the dangers posed by radioactive fallout.
Military personnel involved in the tests were
exposed to dangerous radiation levels, and many
have suffered severe health problems.
The indigenous communities living where
the tests were carried out were not
consulted or informed of the dangers
they faced. Many were forced to abandon their
ancestral lands and relocate to other areas.
I think we all as Australians have an obligation
to make sure that this never happens again I think
it's a very very dark era in Australian
history and we need to guard against
government secrecy and under the table agreements
between Australia and the so-called great powers.
Despite the passage of time, the true
extent of the damage caused by the tests
remains unknown. The legacy of the nuclear
tests in Australia is a chilling reminder
of the dangerous power physics has given us
and the lasting consequences of our actions.
This video covered a serious topic and if
you're looking for something a little more
light-hearted to watch next I'd like to tell
you about a new video series that I'm involved
with. Earlier this year I traveled across
New Zealand with some friends as part of
a competitive game-based reality show called
Jet Lag it was a fun and stressful way to see
the country and it was a chance for me to show
off a different side of my personality since we
filmed it in a relaxed vlog style format. Jet
Lag is a Nebula first show meaning that it is
always one episode ahead on Nebula compared
to YouTube. But what is nebula well it is a
creator-owned streaming service that I just
joined and it allows YouTubers to create cool
and ambitious content that they wouldn't be able
to make otherwise. Buying a nebula subscription
is a way to support me directly and a bunch of
other creators. They have originals such as Up
and Atoms Is Math Invented or Discovered and they
have a new feature called Nebula Classes teaching
a range of topics related to content creation.
If you sign up using my link below you support
me directly and get access to Nebula and Nebula
classes for around 2.50 per month or 30 USD per
year. Using my link gives 40% off the annual
plan. If you join Nebula you can also listen
to the exclusive podcast The Layover which I'm
on with the guys from Jet Lag talking all about
the decisions that we made on the show and what
happened behind the scenes. Thanks for watching
this video and thanks to my Patreon supporters
including today's Patron cat of the day Jan.